they find a formula and sticks and stick
to it yeah so it's very unstimulating
that's why every video is like top three
reasons why you should do blank and
you're like
[Music]
let's talk about this because I feel
like a lot of people think this is easy
and they all want to do it probably to
what the reality of it may be different
depending on what you guys have to say
what is it like to start a clothing
brand oh wow what's it really like
because everybody goes oh I'm gonna
start cooling about you hear it every
day from different people that they're
just gonna do it but it's probably not
as simple I think it's one of the
hardest things ever and even the people
that I talk to that have done at a super
high level so I have like like two
mentors right now
um they started like a bunch of skate
Brands back in the get uh back in the
day like Maddox the kai those guys
and they told me like
the problems that you face with
production things that pop up it never
goes away it's the surprises yeah
there's always [__] delays whatever just
part of the game it's just if you like
the industry enough because you always
think like as like a business owner
you're trying to streamline things okay
cool I can like mitigate this and I can
forecast more about a little more cash
flow like money solves our problems and
you're like you're trying to think big
and smooth it out but it never really
goes away because some [__] will always
happen but if you love it and that's
part of it then you'll continue to keep
growing yeah I think it's also about
like I mean
it's it's such a it's a game that could
be so many different things depending on
like what you want in the end product
right yeah it's like I think having a
vision of like really what you want to
accomplish is like a really important
thing like the most important I would
say right because you could make super
dope clothes that are super unique and
like they come from a place of like
passion like I don't do something
different about it and you can sell them
to a certain degree but not make that
much profit but you've sold enough to
keep the business going and people are
happy and you're changing the game a
little bit or you can dilute your
product a little bit more widen out the
audience right make a little bit more
money but you're doing less of your
changing the game or you're doing less
of change in the game maybe that doesn't
pay off as much for you and your soul
you know what I mean so I think for us
for Mike and I with shell Corp it's been
a lot of like trying to do both as much
as we can like we we both have these
fashion inclinations and things we love
about fashion we want to kind of see
this and now I want to make clothes that
we want to wear we want to make you know
everything done to like the way pants
fit the way a shirt fits how it looks
how it looks and summer versus the
winner this and that and but then the
financial side of it is like you're
still running a business you have to
make these sales you have to make a lot
of these sales right so it's like even
if you love this shirt you can only sell
it in certain colors because only
certain colors might sound if you think
the best one is this color but that
people really like the color as much so
it's really finding that balance between
like what you want to create as an end
product and also being a business person
it's like how do we keep this business
scaling how do we keep it growing yeah
and like we're constantly blocking that
line obviously you want to do both as
much as you can
um so I think it's been a big learning
cover for us us is like
what to sacrifice and when to keep the
business growing but also staying true
to ourselves I think most people go into
it with the more like art mindset and
creative mindset like who I want to like
do these things yeah but then it really
is almost a spectrum of like do you want
to make art or do you want to have a
business and then it's it's literally
almost like a sliding scale
because it's it's like very opposite
things yeah like if you're trying to do
like bespoke stuff one-off stuff it's
not very profitable but if you can go
this way and you're making like a Fruit
of the Loom undershirt it's extremely
profitable but it probably kills your
soul like creatively right so it's kind
of like finding where it's at and then
one of my other mentors he started
Hurley and uh he ended up selling Harley
Jesus Christ one of the guys that
started Hurley uh they there's two guys
that started he sold it to Nike and then
he helped Run Nike SB for 12 years so he
knows a lot and then he was like pretty
much breaking down like how clothing
business works and he goes like what
I've seen across businesses from tattoo
shops to clothing to food and everything
like it's usually there's this one thing
that makes up 60 to 70 of your sales
like a staple shirt staple thing yeah
like yeah even if you go to a tattoo
shop it's like all the flash art and
then there's probably the the one guy
that wants a crazy custom thing but you
got to do a lot ton of flash art all day
long you know oh let me get the [__]
heart whatever take two birds yeah and
so he was like he's like what do you I
said but what about Nike you know when
you're young you're like trying to like
understand the situation I'm like but
now he comes on all kinds of crazy [__]
[__] vapormax maximum air with you
know the [__] ethereum I got no shoes
wow he's got those Nikes this is fly
knit [__] what's that was crazy I
know you were such a high beast and then
he was like speaker head and he was like
what do you think is Nike's number one
seller I think Jordan and he goes no
dude white Air Force once wow and I was
like and he goes do you think those kill
their shoe designer soul I was like [__]
yeah he goes it does but he goes but
because of this and they push this it
gives them the like billion dollar
annual budget to do the r d for the
[__] crazy other [__] they want to
like play around with you know he's like
so you have to earn your right to
experiment and earn your right to be
creative and I was like like that's so
true so like my only experience is like
fan merch and also dabbling into like
the small Niche brands that we started
well now June B has merch we have merch
but I think most of my Concepts have
been merch like not so much or like fan
merch or like even if we when we created
go For Broke I feel like it was still an
extension of fan merch it wasn't a
product that we created without a fan
base
and and I mean it had its own like I
guess brand and life that exists Beyond
JK right but then
um I would I would think like the people
that are asking this question or the
people that are getting into fashion
right they probably want to be like kiss
or they probably want to be like like
supreme or like a streetwear brand or
maybe even a designer brand where they
are a successful artist where it appears
to be a successful artist right because
we all know like luxury Brands it's all
lvmh or whatever like it's the Bernal
guy right like in his family that runs
all of those Brands but then
um when you when those Brands come up
and before they're bought by them
there's history or stories like a family
leather working group or like over the
years you know they develop it like like
the the shoe guys like the Aldo and then
the [__] you know Louboutins or
whatever right it's like one guy one
artist somehow Hollywood
celebrity gets a hold of it and it goes
like super crazy and then like
it seems like that's the dream it's kind
of like I want to be a director like
Tarantino someone who is the artist but
also gets to stay who they are and sell
but then I'm like do they really stay
who they are or they're just good at
like being at the Forefront innovating
and also be a business person like Tesla
so I'm like that's that's kind of like
where I'm like in the beginning we might
be very naive and think that you're just
a true innovator
and you have no business sense but you
just crush it because you're so original
but I'm like I'm not I'm not sure if
that's the the case that might just be
something that you imagine that's why I
think it's like what Christian is saying
is so important like finding out what
your goal is is your goal to make really
cool stuff or is your goal to grow a
business or is your goal to like solve a
problem and then that way you can manage
your expectations because I think most
people is a lot of people that I talk to
their goal is to they just want to be in
the industry because it seems so fun so
whether it's making clothes for surf or
making clothes for power lifting or
making clothes for streetwear they just
want to be in this world and do the fun
things that they get to do like throw
like little parties and stuff like that
but then they they their Idols are guys
that are crushing it and making a [__]
ton of money and but that's like the
business route so you probably need to
get way better at business than you are
at design or like oh material right yeah
but if you get hyper focused on just the
business then you can lose some of the
creativity side of it and then like
it'll always be like the grass is
greener where you see somebody else
taking a chance and you're like oh [__]
I want to do that you know what I mean I
think it's probably building a character
like in a video game like you only have
so you have like 10 stat points to
allocate right parameters for like how
you jump and how fast you go on your
strength and you get to choose where you
want to give it and it's like you try to
pick the best stats to kind of get you
through the game and then when you get
opportunities to add more stats on then
you kind of add those attributes there
but like be okay knowing that you only
get so many at the beginning and you're
going to keep growing as this game goes
along and don't try to just like load up
one side because you're gonna die right
the first boss so it's like it's kind of
like that I think it's a lot of patience
so like you know go to business then
switch back all right like let's get
creative all right we took we broke even
there all right let's go to the physical
the business oh I get creative and I
think as those things continue to grow
and like but we're also still trying to
find our staple we think we know what it
is we're still trying to make more
Staples that can keep the business going
forever and like all right cool we can
just be creative now about this while
people just buy this t-shirt forever
that's what Supreme [__] did Supreme
wasn't being crazy creative ever it's
just a red box yeah they also just took
things that were already kind of hot and
put their name on it yeah right right
right like they feel like new they were
just trolls that got
accidentally successful well not
accidentally but you know the intention
was like oh let's like parody and make
fun of these things
and then they're like now becoming what
they were parroting right yeah yeah
that's true that's how counterculture
kind of works right it's like it becomes
the mainstream right and then something
else comes then something else comes on
eventually yeah and takes the piss out
of that and it's like no [__] this and
then that becomes a thing until it you
know so in the slider scale of like
um traits that shell Corp had when it
started what were some of the things
that you spent those points on when you
started earning like where did you focus
media media huge on me visibility and
stuff part of me like having visibility
for the brand
um no investing a lot of time and energy
into the media like for sure the also
the designs the designs were super like
the original designs that Mike mocked up
were great and then even like when we
started going to our next stuff that we
were both very much collaborating on
like we were always I think pushing the
envelope a little bit Yeah like these
pants I'm wearing like these are like a
combination of like two different kinds
of pants like they're you know they're
they're Sleek but they're like they're
kind of upscale but they also could be
on the street you know what I mean uh to
catch you guys up to speed like shell
Corp from my perspective looks almost
like a modern slightly edgy gentleman's
wear yeah it's like upscale streetwear
because they have you guys have like you
guys have like cut and so trench coats
and like like button-ups with like thin
material
yeah it looks it looks dope thank you if
you go the media route because that was
already one of your strengths 100 we
were like all right we got this dub
closed all right well what are we good
at like I think always lean into
whatever you're good at and like [__]
like super serve your Niche at all times
all right me and Mike we don't we're not
coming from a fashion World we're not
coming from a business world but we know
[__] media all right let's [__]
play that tune as hard as we can bring
people in and once they're watching oh
look these clothes are super sick so we
made a bunch of media that incorporated
things we like you know action and like
Heroes also a lot of comedy and like a
lot of like satire and we just [__]
invested in that a lot and then you know
promoting like we always want to do that
always and then people came and they
stayed like now like when we drop and we
do a big drop we always do a big round
of media like around center around it
and it's always a big deal that helps
push everything and people look forward
to right now how do you work out the
Kinks with like production and like
finding out how to Source like what the
fabric is who's making it we have a
partner like a we have a production
partner who helps us like with our
fulfillment but like a lot of times
Michael find clothes that we like from
wherever over the years might be in our
closet we might be shopping like we go
to the flea market except we like and
we'll bring stuff like all right we like
the the way the sleeve drops here we
don't like this material we want
something lighter we'll just like try to
explain it the best we can to the guys
who help us out and they Source it we
get samples we say okay cool we need
this to be a different color a different
bit lighter we're just trying our best
to communicate what we want until we get
the product that we like it in yeah
there's a guy that's pretty cool in the
OC
um shout out to the crystal leverage but
he owns like a design house oh Chris The
Leverage yeah yeah yeah yeah so what's
cool is like he's someone I would say
from at least my level he looks like
he's made it or he's been able to do
what he's been doing for like
over 20 years so that's a lot of
stability he runs a lot of Brands out of
his design house and uh you can just
tell someone when they really enjoy the
industry because every country he goes
to he goes and buys denim from that
country and then so you'll have a room
full of just all random denim so it's
almost like a denim Museum so it's like
different era different content a
different country wash from different
water and you can just so like he's like
a denim expert and you're just like oh
[__] that's really cool to see like a
lot of times people think
um like people they want work and then
like not work like work life balance but
the people that get really good at stuff
it's a 24-hour thing it's just part of
it it's them yeah yeah I put something
about clothing too like I I was telling
you like I walk into a place and they're
selling clothes I think it's a different
thing I might not think this is a great
idea or it might look good on me but I
think it has something that I might want
to take from one day I will buy the
thing I might not wear it but I'll keep
it in my closet and one day I will be
like oh you know what had that that
[__] shirt and log and I'll pull it
out and like oh that's what we need to
do and I I can tell when something's
like got something enough that I'll
stalk it I have [__] in my closet now
that I bought like at like a thrift
store in Japan in like 2017 that like I
don't know what I'm gonna call upon it
but one day I will that's something
about it that I know I still do that
with me and Mike like every time we sit
down like another year like oh what do
you want to make this year I'm like you
know what I think it's gonna be hot and
I'll go get some [__] I bought five
years ago I'm like I think this wasn't
ever hot back then I think this could be
cool if we did this thing so it's like I
definitely love it enough to always be
on the lookout for like you know just
pieces that inspire me like say it was
like comedy though same with like
writing and just making things it's like
it's a part of you you always want to
make [__] right so just stay open to it
what's your favorite barbell product
that you guys created that's like this
was an aha product like aha in terms of
for me as like the like it knocked it
out it performed great knocked it out of
the park that's the funny part nothing
that I like crushed and all of the stuff
that I'm like man that's whatever
crushes because I think that's yeah
because I think I'm actually way more
artist than businessman so if it Vibes
with me it probably goes over people's
heads you know what I mean like like a
pop musician like the stuff that like
let's say Ed Sheeran listens to is
probably [__] crazy right right the
stuff that he makes everyone's like oh I
like it you know I could say I just clap
on the tune on the floors right but he's
listening to pop out on some [__]
Irish [__] folk music for some crazy
yeah [__] that [__] so for me like some
of my favorite things is uh one was our
our dry duffel did I give you one yeah
so our driver it's a it's a like
military grade mesh and I was extreme
extremely inspired because when I did my
when I got scuba certified yeah a mesh
bag is standard in like that world okay
right because you put your wetsuit your
fins all that stuff in there and then so
you literally put it on and then half
the day on the boat everything is dry
and I was like this should be in the gym
world because we got knee sleeves we got
boxing gloves we got hand wraps in that
chair out
so when I came back from that trip I was
really inspired by that so I created our
dry duffel where uh the whole top of it
is like military grade mesh so you can
breathable it's breathable and then that
way none of your gear ever stinks or
smells whatever
um and I was like really proud of that
that's what I took something from one
world brought into this world when we
sold it it did all right and then we do
like another backpack that just looks
like a Jansport or something any other
[__] regular streetwear style
backpack with a laptop yeah like that
one I like that one and
[__] sells out in like 30 minutes I
wanted one I'm like I did one it has
everything everyone else has laptop
sleeve iPad sleeve it's like something
that's like if someone goes hey what
should a backpack have and I just got
these five things it was like that oh
just so standard huh boom can I say
something versus the dried duffel where
I'm like yeah go ahead as a consumer of
simple things sometimes I just want
something simple
that's the thing it kills it kills
artists I know but for me like I like
that like I like it that it's simple and
then it has the barbell logo you know I
mean that's all I need okay because I'm
like you know what do we play a song of
like F minor and then you're like no no
happy birthday
do you have a product that's like a
favorite product of yours that was like
not a seller in the public market for
sure but I was actually gonna relate to
viral videos where it's like almost
every single time that like Jimmy and
I've had a video go viral even myself
like my personal stuff like it wasn't
something I thought was gonna go ever
the Beat Drop video for one that was a
video we dropped as a [__] Plan B
like we had like we did that video like
on the back of another video we were
shooting we shot it it's a good idea
boom we make it and then we had like
dropped several videos
before that it was just kind of sitting
in the like whatever the queue of if we
needed it one day we're in Cabo for
spring break and we were trying to
upload a video from Cabo and it was like
a regular four minute sketch but it
wouldn't up but it kept dying halfway
through because whatever the Wi-Fi was
bad we didn't want to like break the
consistency of dropping so we dropped it
make a beat drop video because it was
like I said 20 seconds or whatever it
was YouTube could handle that it uploads
we didn't even look at it close the
laptop all right we go back to Cabo
partying and while we're out in Copper
everyone's like dude the new video dude
the new videos crashed we're like what
what like couldn't think about it wake
up the next morning like two million
views like what and that happened to
several times because it was just
supposed to be like a placeholder like
whatever and the ones we put a lot of
effort into and like money and budgets
I did okay every now and then it hit but
like a lot of time I noticed that
pattern happening a lot when you're
creating stuff but then don't you think
like once you kind of go like all right
if this is the stuff that works let me
get into the mindset of just creating
really basic [__] and just spamming that
like but that's how we that's how the
internet turns into what it is today
yeah and that's what I was gonna say if
that's what it is now because people go
oh I don't have to try that hard to go
viral all right I'm just gonna do that
and get in the run and so that's why
creators I think are actually not
creators they're actually business
people now ah there's a lot of airflow
Air Force One makers yeah and not so
much like flying at me because they know
that's what works they find a formula
and sticks and stick to it yeah so it's
very unstimulating that's why every
video is like top three reasons why you
should do blank and you're like
a lot of videos I'll see today are like
this is how you get big on Tick Tock
it's like what the [__] you're on Tick
Tock talking about how to get big on
Tick Tock and then that video goes viral
and I'm learning from someone that has
uh less followers than me on Instagram
the shade yeah it's like oh five
successful ways on Instagram or let me
see this 10 000 followers I mean you
seem like you're doing something right
so let me write these notes
yeah man let's follow there's more views
sometimes too so how's that pops yeah
guys uh check out obviously volleyball
Brigade shell Corp and June B's got new
hats yeah
hats baby corduroy hats